This has to be seen to be believed, and it's
almost as sad as it is unbelievable a Donald
Trump has forced his way back on to Twitter.
He's tweeting by writing letters, which are
then published and retweeted by his kids and
friends.
This is a former president, folks, you might
recall that Donald Trump was banned from Twitter
sometime ago for constantly, persistently,
endlessly, stubbornly inciting violence and
telling lies about the 2020 election results.
He is now putting out statements through his
Save America PAC, which are often duplicates
from things he's posting to gab some kind
of right wing social network.
And it's all on Donald Trump letterhead.
But these are now tweets.
He is he is publishing letters that are just
tweets.
Yesterday, Trump put one out that says statement
by Donald Trump, 44th president of the United
States.
Wouldn't it be fantastic if the legendary
Herschel Walker ran for the United States
Senate in Georgia?
He would be unstoppable, just like he was
when he played for the Georgia Bulldogs.
And in the NFL, he is also a great person.
Run, Herschelle, run.
That's a tweet.
In written letter form, he figured out how
to force his way back on to Twitter.
I believe this is a ban evasion, but we'll
talk about that.
And then Donald Trump junior reposts it.
And before you know it, Trump's tweeting,
writing tweet length letters posted by his
family to Twitter.
He then sends a much crazier one.
And this is I almost feel bad for the guy.
This is one of the saddest statements I've
ever seen from a President Trump, clearly
triggered by yesterday's announcement from
Joe Biden that the US has secured an additional
hundred million doses of the JNJ vaccine.
Donald Trump, quote, tweeting, sort of writing
a letter where he says this is it's almost
sad, quote, I hope everyone remembers when
they're getting the covid-19 often referred
to as the China virus vaccine, that if I wasn't
president, you wouldn't be getting that beautiful
shot for five years at best and probably wouldn't
be getting it at all.
I hope everyone remembers.
Isn't there something really sad about that?
These really are tweets now.
I don't you know, what can Twitter really
do?
Can Twitter ban statements, written statements
from the former president?
No, I don't think so.
I don't even think that they should.
But if we're honest, this does violate the
spirit of the ban.
I mean, it is ban evasion and it's all so
strange and desperate.
And I know that some
are saying nobody should even mention that
Trump is doing this.
You're amplifying it by sharing it.
This isn't about amplifying the content.
This is about how Donald Trump has figured
out a way in his desperation to be back on
Twitter.
He's figured out a way to circumvent the VAT,
the ban.
It's about desperation.
It's about tech regulation.
It's about so many other things that we've
been talking about on this show.
But some aspect of this is also just really,
really sad.
I imagine Trump sitting there at Mar a Lago
eating his KFC and drinking his diet and his
malts as he likes to drink.
And watching Joe Biden show up with, as we
saw yesterday, the JNJ CEO and the Merck CEO
and announcing everybody's going to be able
to get a vaccine by the end of it.
We're going to have enough vaccines for everybody
by the end of May.
Not necessarily.
Everyone will get one by then.
It's going to take some time to inject them.
We're doing one hundred million dose deal.
We may have so many doses, we're going to
be giving them to other countries.
And Trump wants to tweet, but he's off Twitter.
So this is what he is now doing.
It's both delusional.
But also a little bit sad in some way.
I'm not going to shed any tears, though, if
that's what you're waiting for.
That's the latest from Trump forcing his way
de facto back on Twitter.